all right well hello everyone my name is
Matt and my name is a coach and we're
here from the Boston Consulting Group
we're in the gamma division of the
Boston Consulting Group which is DSG's
advanced analytics team a bit of
information about the Boston Consulting
Group because I can imagine that it
might be a new name to some of you we
were founded in around the the 60s by a
guy named Bruce Henderson in Boston
that's also why we're called the Boston
Consulting Group at this point we're
more a completely global firm
we're like active on all continents and
we really focus on management consulting
we focus on about like 20 practice areas
so that means that like a lot of we
cover almost all industries as well and
yeah so during most of what we did was
its management consulting and what we
really saw about like four or five years
ago was that more and more of our cases
actually involve advanced analytics and
to kind of like capture all that
knowledge and expertise within BCG like
all the events and Olympics cases were
put under what the gamma umbrellas like
yeah BCG gamma is the analytics in a
powerhouse of BCG what we saw was the
traditional consulting tools of
PowerPoint in Excel don't don't work
anymore and that's a common
misconception that a lot of people have
about analytics consulting is that
you're just gonna be working in Excel
you're not gonna actually get to do any
real data science and that's absolutely
not the case
from Matt and i's experience there it's
very much real data science using the
exact same open source Python
technologies that everyone has been
presenting here today so as matt said
fully global we've we've met a lot of
people here who are looking for roles
and potentially new jobs in new york but
also potential jobs and Europe or India
so for anyone looking it's global we
sponsor visas it's not not just new
york-based
and further what from what Matt said
we've we've done a lot of work it's it's
an interesting opportunity because you
get to you get to see a lot
things from various practice areas so
there's things that are very consumer
facing so personalized marketing or how
you combine the data science teams with
into two very large organizations that
already exist we do product facing work
so building a scheduling algorithm or
building a pricing or promotion tool
we've done operations works that's
prediction predictive maintenance work
or optimizing how effect flows through a
factory we've done network analysis so
using using some of like network X or
some graph type out graph databases to
understand how how light emails flow
through a company or understand how
you're gonna do how you're gonna design
like sales areas for for various
businesses or understanding where you're
gonna put new store locations if you're
gonna enter a new city so it's a lot of
like any area of data science is
something that will probably touch
because so many companies have these
huge amounts of data they're just
collecting and don't necessarily know
what to do it so we get to come in and
help help with that we are not just data
scientists we've got data engineers
software engineers architects DevOps
people so it's it's definitely a full
stack a full stack business yeah so to
kind of give an example of the work that
we've been doing it's actually a project
I worked on we've kind of want to
highlight one case and this is a
partnership at BCG launch with KLM about
two years ago KLM is part of the air
france-klm group it's a European carrier
based out in Amsterdam and it's it's a
it's a pretty big airline and as you
guys might know airlines are pretty
operationally heavy in their day to day
business and it's something that it's
also very competitive market so so using
data is something that Airlines actually
have been doing for quite a while mainly
when it comes to revenue management and
things like that but recently also to
kind of you know improve the operations
in their in their day to day or in their
in their their whole business working so
yeah we have a quick video that kind of
like explains what we did here
we are klf we are aviation pioneers
Dutch at heart we dare to reach out
initiate and explore new horizons
[Music]
we're at the Boston Consulting Group we
are known and trusted for strategic
advice and for achieving impact we put
decades of experience to work taking our
approach to innovation to the next level
together we leverage the power of
artificial intelligence and new
technology jointly we offer solutions
that will change airline operations with
a huge impact on customer satisfaction
and operating costs we bring together
BCG consultants BCG gamma data
scientists and KLM operations experts to
solve complex operational challenges
together on heavily disrupted days tens
of thousands of passengers for delayed
or rebook in this complex network even a
small change can have a huge impact
today
our artificial intelligence already
helps us to look like each smarter in
the case of a passenger now show this
technology reduces the delay impact on
other passengers and make sure that
every passenger travels with their own
bag but we do more based on advanced
prediction models our tools are Nicolas
to make sure one delay doesn't impact
other flights
create efficient crew schedules and
minimize the impact of disruptions for
crew Network and our customers
our tools support employees with the
right information at the right time we
enable them to make the best decisions
big or small whether it is a single
no-show or hundreds of delays together
we have taken the first step the next
steps are to bring this technology to
other airlines we bring AI to life we
make it usable in the real world today
turning airline operations into a
competitive advantage launching a unique
and globally leading partnership between
KLM and the Boston Consulting Group yeah
so a bit of a promotional video of
course I mean I imagined our no airline
executives in this room but if there are
like be sure to reach out so yeah I mean
it really what the video does like show
is that it's just kind of like all the
different aspects that come with like
running an airline and with together
with KLM and that's really also about
the video highlights it's really like a
collaboration it's not much like a like
a client consultant partnership it's
really together with KLM we've built out
five tools basically and these five
tools also like interact with one
another the video kind of went over them
but I would kind of want to dive a
little bit deeper in exactly how they
work so so on the basically the five
tools are our Pathfinder through
Harbinger and Pathfinder is plane
allocation it's kind of if you if you
booked a ticket it will tell you what
plane you are in and you get you can
also choose a seat but which physical
machine actually flies that route is
typically not known yet and and that's
calculated about like a month to like
two weeks before and all the way to kind
of like your like more day of operations
tools that
assign which pilot and which crew fly or
your your airplane the funny thing with
all these tools is that that they all
interact with one another so they're big
optimization heavy tools most of the
they're the base of most of them are
integer programs I don't know how from
people here are with mathematical
optimization and from Pathfinder which
basically assigns the actual machines to
routes to century which basically at the
day of operations when you know an
airport is shut down or the crazy
thunderstorm somewhere which means that
planes are grounded or planes can
actually not land or take off it
reshuffles all the planes again
- like Harbinger which at that point
decides like okay well a lot of pilots
come in late they might not make their
connections because you know we think
typically customers only make
connections but it's actually potted to
make connections as well suitcases make
connections as well it realized which
which pilot in which crew flies flies on
which plane and maybe that sounds a
little bit like clear to you but you
have to understand that you know pilot
like labor loss it's not just actually
Union said loss but it's actual labor
law said by like federal governments are
incredibly strict pilots can only fly
that many hours and if you have a pilot
that cannot fly a plane anymore and a
plane is in Fargo North Dakota
you're in a bit of a trouble right
because you're not gonna very quickly
drum up another pilot so that means that
the pilot has to sleep you have to get a
hotel it's like an eight-hour delay
immediately on your on your flight so
making sure and keeping these things
into account and optimizing for that are
really big cost Schafer's for for
airlines so a quick overview of exactly
what Pathfinder does Pathfinder is the
tool that assigns machines or metal or
iron or birds like Airlines have like
the craziest terminologies for for just
a plane - two routes to do that the main
goal of Pathfinder is typically to just
robusta phi2 schedules so what we build
is the underlying the underlying input
in this model is a delay prediction
which is you know I cannot go into too
many details it's always intellectual
property of course but it's a it's
basically an artificial intelligence
algorithm that like predicts what the
delay is and it feeds that into a big
optimization program basically like a
robust optimization program that then
that knows how to deal with these
certain distributions by kind of like
changing to underline
you know like solution space while still
keeping you know some sort of
computational intractability that that's
typically like a big issue if you
actually start optimizing over in
certainty in order to like assign these
planes to two routes and and at the end
of the day what you get is that is that
it just resolves a lot of planes in
order to create a more robust schedule
yes yeah so it it maximizes robustness
but actually the funny thing is once you
have that whole integer program set up
with these distributions underlying it
there are a lot of other use cases you
can really use this framework for right
because this this framework is nothing
more than a pretty like precise
mathematical representation of the
operations that the airline has two
weeks before so if there are other
things that you want to do friends is
like maximize utility you can actually
do that as well by very simply swapping
in and out the cost function this is
something we have done within with an
agent carrier it's pretty cool I was not
able to like show the demo here but we
have a tool that just reads in I ate a
data which is publicly available plain
data you know if you're flying or if you
a relative or you flying you can track a
plane you can see what plane that is
that data is readily available and you
you put it in this mathematical
representation you change the cost
function to you know maximize utility
you say you can you have to be on the
ground for at least an hour because
connections need to be made and a plane
needs to be re really restocked with
food and all that and what you do is you
could just see that we we saw that like
all the routes of this agent carrier had
it could actually fly with like five
less planes so these things are things
that for an airline are actually
incredibly incredibly valuable because
these five planes means you can fly them
to like other routes and that just
really greatly increases the revenue of
of these of these big carriers and in
another way you can by just changing by
changing objective functions or cost
functions it's nothing more than a
simulation tool right so you can you can
see like what would happen or by adding
in other constraints in this you're like
what would happen if we actually force
planes to be on the ground for two hours
because maybe the the the reservations
Department says like I let's have planes
on the ground for two hours because we
have a very big Airport like you might
have in Atlanta or in in Dallas and it
would be better we see if we increase it
to two hours more customers actually
make their connections and you can just
see what the impact that has on a day to
day a business of an airline so yeah as
much as we typically the typical use
case we see for airlines is to actually
maximize robustness and what you still
see of course is that when the actual
day of operations come is that you know
like a thunder storm hits
typically unfortunately we cannot really
predict thunderstorms that accurately
two weeks in advance as you guys might
know and thunderstorms in particular are
especially in the United States a big
problem for airlines because it means
that the airport is closed people are
like like you're just not allowed to be
on the ground as an actual worker so you
like no one can load two suitcases into
the plane people can not stock the
suitcases people gonna drive around not
to mention that there's also a bit of a
safety aspect that you shouldn't
necessarily be flying through like
massive thunder clouds so at that like
once the day of operations actually
comes what you sometimes see in airlines
are quite often seen airlines is that
you just have to like recalculate and
reoptimize your whole your whole doing
of business and that's something this
tool is called sentry it's actually
something I've worked on myself a lot
and the interesting thing here is that
the structure of it is relatively
similar to Pathfinder we actually
typically don't even include the the you
know the robustness so the the the
problem the delay distributions why is
that it's because like you know 50
minutes out things are pretty
deterministic you know what connections
passengers have you know what
connections you know crew has you know
what plane needs to be where for
maintenance requirements these things
are pretty set in stone the only actual
like big problem that you have with
these things is that you know even if a
thunderstorm suddenly happens over
Chicago O'Hare and everything needs to
be recalculated
you don't want this there's this
algorithm to come up with an answer you
know like two weeks from now because at
that point useless right so you actually
don't even want that answer to be like
30 minutes from now you really wanted
within the next 10 minutes and these
massive integer programs are are solved
by you know branch and bound algorithms
or other mathematical algorithms that
are that have very very near exponential
like complexity so the real trick here
is kind of more like how do you deal
with the mathematical formulation and
how do you use certain decomposition
algorithms to actually really decompose
this this whole yeah this algorithm in a
way that we still come to like an answer
within like you know under five minutes
and to give you a little bit of an
example of how big this problem is I
mean we deal with about you have a lot
of like binary variables that basically
tells you
does this playing flight is route yes or
no these binary variables you know it's
a you have if you have a hundred planes
and a hundred routes that means already
have 10,000 binary variables but if that
plane can also and that route can take
off every minute of the day you can
imagine that these variables is explode
quite fast so we you know you're
typically like in a millions of
variables and each variable can we one
or zero so the the you know the the big
solution space here is 2 to the power of
a couple million I mean you two to the
power for a couple million is just like
so big that is something that like a
human cannot even remotely understand I
think they're two to the power 40,000
atoms in the whole universe so you can
imagine like how big 2 to the power of a
couple million is so yeah that's it's
it's always interesting to to work on
these problems to speed them up and to
make sure that you know you do come to a
solution and and and really what we see
a lot here is that basically like a once
you actually aren't able to decompose
them and you can find you can find
solving algorithms and might not
necessarily rely on like libraries out
there writing them up in like packages
like numba or like other like really
like easily to paralyze and like quick
Python packages is something that we
leverage a lot so
makes sense so the site the second half
of this of this talk is is mostly ensure
is is gonna speak about how we use how
what certain frameworks we use within
BCG to ensure code success from day one
so as as an industry consulting often
has short timelines managers that aren't
necessarily technical you're interacting
with clients i client side people who
maybe are even scared of SQL or have
never seen a database in their life and
so all of the complexity that underlies
a data science solution is hard hard to
explain sometimes and hard to put into
hard to put into timelines so there's a
number of things we use internally to
ensure that code is code is successful
from from day one and that we can take a
solution from a proof-of-concept so for
example Centurion one maybe like one
certain class of plane so maybe just
like all of all of Americans like one
specific fleet that leaves from
LaGuardia as like a proof of concept
then it works every time LaGuardia has a
thunderstorm but then American would say
hey now let's expand this to all of our
airplanes and all of our airports in the
entire US and the runtime has to still
stay under five minutes and so if it's
something like that then you have to
start thinking about these things from
day one of your project to make it so
that three months in once we've
developed proof of concept or six months
in you're not going to say all right
you're gonna be paying us for the next
three months while we completely rewrite
our code base and you you're gonna see
nothing for the next three months that's
not something that you can do so so so
the first first couple of bits that
we've noticed is to spend time early
when you're starting a data science
project to really define your project
structure and a toolset whatever code is
is well structured from the beginning
it's easier to onboard new team members
it's easier to explain what your code is
doing to people who are a little bit
skeptical of machine learning algorithms
whenever it's you you want to start
focusing on scalability earlier rather
than later so one code is modular it's
easier to maintain it's easier to swap
out components
one thing to another it's easier to
switch out data sources it's easier to
switch algorithms so as Matt was saying
going from a going from one one class of
a linear problem to another class of
linear problem it's easy to switch
whatever that bit is kind of abstracted
away and you have a little internal API
to say I'm gonna submit something to it
and I'm gonna get a result from it and
the internal details of it as long as it
looks the same I can measure the quality
of it but then switch one out to another
and then finally making sure the quality
stays high and in this in a space where
we're tight deadlines are unavoidable so
ensuring that you're going through a
robust code review process ensuring that
code components are tested will lead
will lead to a solution that doesn't
break when new features are added or
when when features are swapped out from
one to the other so there's six six key
principles that we've noticed for the
more senior people in the room hopefully
none of these really come as a surprise
but it's important to write them down
and put them into a framework that every
single team has whenever they get
started they start with making sure the
version control is used for everything
it infrastructure is reproducible that's
a big DevOps principle clean robust
modular code we're not writing functions
that are like two hundred lines long
we're not writing functions that just
say run the code documentation that's
up-to-date so anyone who joins the
project or if you're explaining what
your project does to a senior manager or
director and the company can understand
what's happening making sure things are
tested from the start and then a good
team team governance process to make
sure that one person is in charge of the
code a person is in charge of
understanding where the data lies
someone's making sure that there's
proper security procedures that are
being followed and then maybe a product
or project manager on top of that to to
guide the overall development of the
code get get is kind of a funny concept
in the data science space itself from
people coming in to data science from a
software engineering background using it
or using version control is something
that of course why wouldn't you for
people entering data science more for
more of a business
analyst background who are used to kind
of Excel sheets or sharepoint or
something like that it takes a bit to
get used to and often times tutorials
that are using Jupiter notebooks like a
learn to code Python and in in a hundred
days type type courses that are using a
lot of Jupiter notebooks to explain
don't necessarily show you how you
version control notebooks don't
necessarily show you how to create
create a branching strategy when you're
adding code don't necessarily show you
how how you how you deal with code
that's not necessarily code that you
yourself wrote and so you starting with
a git repository defining a brand of
branching workflow so feature branches
effects branches bug fix branches run
branches for each each various class of
thing that's that's running in the code
is important creating small branches is
something that we've we've seen we've
seen that works really well sometimes
new developers can struggle with that
whenever there's just they here's all of
my changes to the code in the last two
weeks style branch those are really
really hard to review don't do that and
then pushing and committing regularly so
you can always revert or rollback code
that you wrote and then something breaks
or something doesn't work then as
expected making sure that you can always
revert back to a to a previous state but
that's a previous state that was maybe
two or three hours ago not a previous
state that was three weeks ago
second is code that runs easily on new
machines scales much faster this is a
core core principle of cloud cloud
development on AWS as your JCP things
that install easily and require little
configuration or great it means you can
spin up a new VM and automatically run
your code on it if you realize you're
running into size constraints resourcing
constraints things that only run on
someone's laptop and are like very
tightly bound to a specific environment
are hard to scale then you have to
invest a couple weeks and in making sure
that you're removing things like
hard-coded paths there's specific
library versions or even understanding
what the environment that you're running
your code on is something that's that
can be hard to just like take out in the
middle of a project so
starting with with environment
technology or just environment best
practices using virtual environments
kondeh environments or docker files is
something that works really well and can
let you port your code from from one
machine to another accessible
accessibility to the code is something
that we we like to focus on a lot as
well so not only should the data
scientists be able to run the code but
ideally even business analysts or
managers should be able to like do a run
of the pipe do a run of the pipeline so
for example with with Pathfinder and and
sentry it's it's exposed as a website
where they can put in input parameters
hit run and then the code runs for them
as well so they if there's a specific
scenario that they want to test they can
do that themselves rather than saying
hey hey Matt or heya coach you're the
data scientist who wrote this code can
you run this scenario in that scenario
for me and I'd spend my next two to
three days playing around with
configuration parameters and running the
code instead of developing new features
or making the code run faster and more
robust so exposing exposing your model
in a way that people can test it who
aren't necessarily the developers
themselves is something that that works
really well and often times they catch
corner cases edge cases that that aren't
things that the developers were thinking
about when when building the one
building the model and then finally
proper abstractions in the code are
critical and not nothing fancy on this
one just making sure that code is
agnostic to like the directory structure
you're storing roll all of your files on
on an s3 bucket or an accurate blob
storage type system as opposed to just
throwing everything on your C Drive
users or backslash home home data type
folder and then whoever tries to run
your code next is going to try to run it
and get into a bunch of permissions
issues and user directory issues and
things like that the next thing that
that we encourage all developers to to
use and all all data scientists uses
assertions and logging wherever possible
- too many too many times what ends up
happening in code is we we build these
crazy crazy
expressive models they're complex they
capture a lot of the complexity of the
problem and then it breaks and then what
what happens now and then you spend all
of this time debugging the model and
everything and it turns out your input
file for like this day transactions for
this day didn't come through and it's a
blank file and you spend eight hours
debugging like what the heck is going on
with my model that it can't handle this
null when it turns out that if you would
have just ensured that there's more than
one transaction per day then you would
have caught this as soon as your ETL
process flag something so data integrity
on the input of your model setting that
up as soon as possible and then also
data integrity on the output of your
model because oftentimes one model feeds
into the next model which feeds into the
next model and then they're combined and
transformed using various api's
internally so ensuring that whatever
comes out of a model makes makes logical
sense then recording important events
for for monitoring and auditing each
each run of your code should ideally be
reproducible so logging like agate hash
to to make sure that I can reproduce
results whenever I want or logging which
versions of data I used on each run is
something that that makes people like
trust the model more whenever they say
oh actually what what happened two
months ago and how is that solution
different from today's solution and then
like doing a doing and doing an analysis
like that is much easier when you store
it exactly what happened two months ago
and then you can recreate that result
today neck documentation is kind of a
tricky topic with with data science
solutions they're complex they're
oftentimes hard to understand and
oftentimes there's a lot of stakeholders
involved who aren't necessarily data
scientists so keeping documentation
tightly coupled with the code through of
using using what a lot of open source
best practice or projects use such as
read the docs or MK Docs is something
that that works well even on internal
projects hosting them on an internal
website and that way you can you can
your documentation goes through the same
it goes through the same it goes through
the same workflow
the rest of the code does so it goes
through pull requests if there's an
urgent update to the documentation that
something has changed that could be a
hotfix branch and then all users know if
there's like a website change or now
they need to go to a different internal
website then then you can you can
immediately put that on the
documentation this also also avoids a
common problem with with internal
documentation structures that like large
companies or people just kind of spam
documentation on various internal
websites and it's completely unorganized
and no one knows where anything is if
it's in the same structure as your code
and it's PR dand reviewed then it makes
it makes it so that the documentation is
something that at least a couple of
people have seen rather than people are
just writing documentation and storing
it wherever it makes sense to them and
then finally writing documentation for
both technical and non-technical
audiences is something that we've we
found to be very critical as someone
who's writing a lot of code it can be
very easy to write documentation that's
super technical it documentation that's
describing what your code is doing and
to to your to your manager or to your
manic really more your managers manager
or your managers managers manager or
some director somewhere a couple levels
up like they don't care what algorithm I
use they care about like what's the
general structure of this how they can
explain this algorithm that I built to
an investor how they can explain this
algorithm to their boss and so writing
writing documentation on multiple levels
is something that's that's very critical
both on me what is the code doing when
someone tries to update it but also what
is the algorithm itself or what is the
general like story behind this algorithm
in the without going into the underlying
like implementation details necessarily
then testing a couple fun quotes
especially about one in top-middle it's
very very common as a data scientist to
just throw out a model that works and
just kind of runs and is hacked together
but to two months down the line six
months down the line your managers not
gonna not gonna oftentimes remember that
it you you hacked this you hacked this
algorithm together and
in just like two days instead of taking
a full two weeks to do it but the poor
quality and happiness of it when it
still doesn't work six months later
you're trying to recreate your thoughts
that's gonna stay until someone fixes
that so making sure that things are
tested things are easily extensible and
actually taking the time to do that is
something that that we've seen a lot of
data scientists become better data
scientist when they end up doing that
and then everything needs to be tested
even things that you don't think should
be tested should be tested because
they're gonna break in the most
unexpected ways when it breaks right a
new test for it when it when you
encounter a new edge case right a new
test for it that way the code the code
reliability is going to significantly
increase over time and you won't run
into the awkward or embarrassing error
of thinking you fix something and then
two to three months later someone comes
to you and says hey like I noticed this
error I thought you'll fix this and then
having to having you get to avoid that
awkward conversation if you if you build
a test case for it and make sure errors
that are once errors are no longer
errors so so to kind of conclude on this
one basically any what what our internal
philosophy is any any code that informs
a decision process is considered
production code so there's it whenever
people use concepts like oh this is just
test code or oh this is just like POC
code like it doesn't need to be like
production grade that's a red flag
things that should things that people
are thinking oh this is just like I'm
gonna replace this later those those are
the types of solutions that end up being
heavily used by by one of our clients
like three four or five years down the
line and then no one's ever refactored
it so any code that anyone writes within
within gamma follows these six
principles it's versioned it's
reproducible on any on any any analysis
it's standardized using a standardized
project structure standardized Python
tooling it's well documented it's tested
and it follows all of BC G's data data
and code governance best practices
so with that we just like to conclude
with a picture of Matt looking down in a
marketing slide of we want a higher data
scientist we want to hire data engineers
and software engineers come join us
where we're growing fast
what's up we have a stand upstairs soon
so come by come get an umbrella come get
a pen it might be raining so an umbrella
is actually useful useful swag but
basically if you know Python or R and
are interested in working on some of the
world's largest analytics problems with
some of the world's largest companies
we'd love to have you questions
sure so most of it I would say most of
it is it's kind of like I mentioned that
earlier it's not necessarily like a like
a consultant client relationship right
where you come in wearing a suit
although I don't wear a suit but like
come in come in wearing a suit and and
talk to your you know like and be the
consultant that says like this is the
way things ought to happen or something
like that it's typically more like a
like a very much a collaboration what we
often see is that the reason why it's a
collaboration as well is because we are
together also building out the client's
capabilities to actually own the
products that we build for them so
typically what we see is that Sprint's
or other you know ways of working like
are fully integrated with the clients
and that like a lot of teams that we
have are not just only gamma it's also
the client in there it's also BCG
classic consultant in there sometimes
it's also people from other verticals of
BCG like blue Tinian it's a it's a it's
more of an IT consultant like vertical
that BCG has and it's like all together
as one group we we kind of like work
towards so certainly common framework
that we end up using for a lot of
engagements is that traditional Med
strategy consulting BCG is working with
an organization they identify a use case
that would work really well for a
advanced analytic solution they
identified that the whatever client
would do much better with a
significantly more robust pricing
algorithm and that's something that
gamma does a lot of so then for further
phase of work gamma comes in will build
them something and then will will help
hire data scientists that are gonna take
over this algorithm so the first one we
kind of like might like largely BCG
somewhat client data scientists then
like the next use case that involves
analytics would be like 50/50 and then
like a third use case would end up being
like mostly client data scientists and
then like one or two BCG data scientists
until they're fully equipped and capable
to handle an internal data science
organization so it's an interesting it's
an interesting same data science
consulting because oftentimes the
the companies we work with it's it's not
Google it's not gonna be over because
they decided their core competency like
they're not gonna they're not gonna
they're not gonna hire a consulting firm
to do that a lot of the clients we work
with our clients and the rest of the
fortune 500 so retailers oil and gas
industrials travel hospitality so
clients that where data is something
that they can very much use but they
don't necessarily have experience hiring
data scientists or building an internal
analytics capability and that's that's
somewhere that we we do a lot of work
with to to make sure that we use like
examples of data science to help them as
a business but also develop them into a
data-driven analytical organization but
sometimes goes as far as like here's our
data figure out what we can do with it
right so they don't even know themselves
like where does the ADA Kim can be
helpful
anyone else do I just cold call on
someone and make you ask a question yes
go ahead yep it can it definitely can so
so an example of a project that that I
would work that I worked on an example
of like out the output of one model
would work and would work into the next
one so it was a markdown optimization
model where you first had to forecast
demand at various price points which to
forecast demand of various price points
you first need to calculate elasticity's
and the demand at various price points
would then flow into an optimization
algorithm to generate the optimal price
in a particular store for a particular
day and so it would be like a chain of
models where first you had to calculate
the elasticity's if if you went to the
colonial talked yesterday that's
basically what they did very similar
model then that would go into a demand
forecasting algorithm and then that one
would flow into an optimization
algorithm which which is a large mixed
integer program and so that's that's why
this slide that I was that I was
referring to of a bit ago on ensuring
that your data is valid both on the
inputs and outputs of your models is
very useful because to debug the third
model down the chain you need to make
sure the outputs of your first to make
sense and so it's it's easy to run into
errors or like nonsense results by the
like outputs of one of the further
models that are down the line but really
it turned out to be a bug in your first
model even though like that one ran
through the pipeline correctly so yes do
test tests always test often as many
things as you can validate do so
so no no one else well thank you so much
for for being here yeah thanks for
coming we'll be upstairs
[Applause]